okay guys today it is November the third
I'm just and this is games what nice
lizard have said they no longer plan to
tell you how many people have World of
Warcraft subscriptions every three
months the company have announced that
there are presently 5.5 million
subscribers this week and that this will
be the last time they publicly divulge a
statistic flooded explained there are
other metrics that are better indicators
of the overall Blizzard business
performance the company will now use
other unspecified engagement metrics to
talk well success in any given period
the 5.5 million figure that stands
currently represents a 100,000
subscriber loss from three months ago
and marks a nine-year low for the
massive MMO so I'm sure you can work out
the logic of not reporting subscribers
any longer yourself Wiles next expansion
entitled Legion will be on display at
blizzcon and a beta is planned for later
this year while Activision Blizzard are
easing away from reporting world of
warcraft statistics they have happily
announced that destiny now has over 25
million registered users as part of its
latest earnings report Activision
revealed that the current user count is
up from the previously announced 20
million report in may and the 16 million
one in February it was also announced
that destiny players are averaging three
hours per day in the game and destiny is
the most watched console game on twitch
Activision Blizzard reported a company
wide net revenue of 1.4 billion which is
slightly down from the one point 17
billion they made this time last year it
was revealed that the revenue from
digital channels made up a massive
sixty-seven percent of the company's
total revenue for the quarter up from
thirty-eight percent last year finally
Activision Blizzard have been really
damn busy today as they've also acquired
candy crush developer King digital
entertainment and what is the latest
massive games industry deal the giant
publisher doled out by
point nine billion dollars per king
whose portfolio includes candy crush
saga and candy crush soda saga two of
the highest-grossing mobile games in the
u.s. Activision Blizzard have said
they're hoping the move will position
the company at the global leader in
interactive entertainment across mobile
console and PC platforms and position
the company for future growth for some
perspective facebook board oculus for
sure billions microsoft bought Mojang's
with 2.5 billion and Disney bought Star
Wars for only four billion let me down
in the comments if you think world of
warcraft subscribers will pick up again
with the release of the new expansion
you can add the game spot we've got
stories on the new warcraft movie
trailer and small out for pc screenshots
on ultra graphics settings that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today as always let me know what you
cared about and I will catch you
tomorrow